Moment, 16.
Okay, ich bin bereit.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Tekra Mesvalo.
Ich bin auf der Station aus Arslan Arstetik.
Ich würde gerne heute mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja. Hauptsache jemand hilft mir.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich kümmere mich um Sie.
Aber am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten, dann können wir schnell führen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiß Reiner Haas.
Reiner Haas.
Frau Haas, können Sie bitte ...
Herr.
Reiner ist ein Mann.
Ja.
Können Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname R-A-I-N-E-R.
Reiner.
Und der Familienname ist Haas.
H-Doppel-A-S.
Doppel-A-S.
Okay.
Vielen Dank, Reiner.
Herr Haas.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 50.
50, okay.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 19.04.76.
19.
Nochmal können Sie bitte ...
19.04.76.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,80 Meter.
Ich bin 1,80 Meter groß.
Ja, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 91 Kilo.
1,90.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Herr Haas.
Was für Sie ist uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich kann mich seit gestern kaum bewegen.
Ich habe solche Schmerzen im Rücken.
Also im unteren Rückenbereich.
Und das strahlt das ganze rechte Bein herunter.
Und ich habe heute Nacht ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Ich wusste nicht, wie ich liegen soll.
Und schon gar nicht wusste ich, wie ich wieder aufstehen soll.
Das war ganz schwierig.
Und ja, also ...
Das sind wirklich heftigste Schmerzen.
Und ich kann mich kaum rühren.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Es tut mir sehr leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Herr Haas, ist Ihnen aufgefallen?
Gibt es eine bestimmte Ursache für die Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe viel im Garten gearbeitet.
Und habe fest sitzende Wurzeln aus dem Boden rausgezogen.
Und viel in gebückter Haltung gearbeitet.
Und danach war es ganz schlimm.
Haben Sie auch etwas schwer gehoben?
Ja, ich habe vor allen Dingen stark gezogen.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Nein, das ging sofort eigentlich los.
Ich habe sofort gemerkt, das war jetzt zu viel.
Und die sind aber immer schlimmer geworden, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, schlimmer. Mit der Sertschwermelung.
Es schießt so richtig rein, ja.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Wie beschreiben Sie?
Stechend, brennend, siehend?
Vielleicht ziehend und brennend eigentlich nicht.
Eher so ziehend und stechend, ja.
Ziehend und stechend, okay. Vielen Dank.
Darf ich fragen, Herr Haas, können Sie sich gut bewegen?
Nein, selbst das Laufen ist mir jetzt schwer gefallen.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass das Bein so ein bisschen kribbelt.
Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, ich kann mich kaum bewegen.
Kein Unbewegen, ja.
Wo ist die Kribbeln? Oder haben Sie noch ein paar Gefühle?
Also ich habe das vor allen Dingen in den Zehen am rechten Bein und so außen am rechten Bein entlang.
Okay. Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwann aus?
Ja, ja, die strahlen das Bein raus, das sagte ich ja. Also bis nach unten hin eigentlich.
Ja, ich meine in den Rücken oder Lenden.
Also ich denke mal, sie strahlen vom Rücken aus über den Po ins rechte Bein rein.
Ja, Rücken.
Herr Haas, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 kein Schmerzen, 10 sehr stärkste Schmerzen.
Also es sind schon Schmerzen, die einem die Tränen in die Augen schießen lassen.
Ich würde sagen 10 natürlich nicht, aber 8 wahrscheinlich schon.
8? Das tut mir sehr leid. Sie haben sehr stärkste Schmerzen.
Ja, ich habe wirklich extrem Schmerzen, sonst wäre ich auch nicht ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Ja, Herr Haas kann Ihnen helfen. Möchten Sie einen Schmerz bitte?
Ja, ich habe natürlich schon was genommen, aber das hat natürlich nicht geholfen.
Haben Sie dagegen zu Hause ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ja, ich habe Ibuprofen genommen.
Wie viel Milligramm haben Sie?
Ich habe 2 mal 600 genommen.
2 mal 100?
600.
600, 2 mal 600.
Ja, aber das hat nicht wirklich was gebracht. Ich kann mich trotzdem noch nicht rühren.
Herr Haas, haben Sie eine ärztliche Rezept? Wie haben Sie diese Ibuprofen?
Ach, die habe ich als Vorrat zu Hause.
Ja, aber bitte nehmen Sie nicht ohne ärztliche Art Medikament.
Ja, aber wenn Sie solche Schmerzen haben, dann nimmt man natürlich Schmerzmittel.
Waren Sie deswegen bei Ihrem Hausarzt?
Nein, ich bin ja hierher gekommen.
Erstmal, ok.
Ok, Herr Haas.
Herr Haas, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, ist Ihr Bein geschwollenes oder gerötetes oder überwärmest beinbemerkt?
Das Bein sieht ganz normal aus, würde ich sagen. Ich habe das jetzt nicht so genau angeguckt, aber ich würde sagen, das fühlt sich nur falsch an.
Aber es sieht glaube ich unauffällig aus.
Ja, ich verstehe. Ok. Haben Sie noch andere irgendwelche Probleme?
Dieses Problem reicht mir vollkommen, ehrlich gesagt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber? Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fiebrig.
Nachschweiß, Kassenschweiß oder so?
Nein, nein, ich habe Rückenschmerzen und ich denke schon, dass es von dieser Gartenarbeit kommt.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Schluckprobleme oder Schmerzen oder Klosgefühl im Hals?
Im Hals? Nein, im Hals habe ich es nicht.
Haben Sie Hüsten?
Hüsten? Nein.
Haben Sie noch Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, Atemnot oder enge Gefühle?
Nein, nein, ich habe nur diese Rückenschmerzen.
Ok. Sie haben schon gesagt, seit gestern sind Sie nicht so gut geschlafen.
Nochmal bitte?
Haben Sie gut geschlafen?
Natürlich nicht, nein, das habe ich Ihnen auch gesagt. Ich konnte gar nicht schlafen, weil ich nicht wusste, wie ich liegen soll.
Ja, ich habe das schon notiert.
Haben Sie noch Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Im Augenblick habe ich das Problem, dass ich nicht weiß, wie ich mich auf die Toilette setzen soll, weil es so weh tut.
Aber ansonsten habe ich da eigentlich keine Probleme.
Ja, ok. Wann lässt du die Kontrolle?
Bitte was? Sie haben aktuell kein Problem.
Nein, nein, ich habe kein Problem.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie schon ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, das Gewicht ist eigentlich immer ziemlich stabil.
Ich muss halt ein bisschen aufpassen. Ich bin Diabetiker, also schon von Kindheit an.
Deswegen ist eigentlich mein Gewicht immer stabil, weil ich versuche vernünftig das Gleichgewicht zu halten.
Sie haben Diabetes-Melotus, Typ 1 oder 2?
Typ 1 habe ich gesagt, also seit der Kindheit.
Ja, ok, Typ 1. Nehmen Sie Insulin.
Ja, ich habe so eine Insulinpumpe.
Ja, eine Insulinpumpe.
Seit Kindheit?
Ja, ja.
Gibt es irgendwelche andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, das was jeder hat, wenn er ein bisschen älter ist. Ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und auch schon eine ganze Weile erhöhte Blutfettwerte.
Da nehme ich aber Statin am Abend und gegen den Blutdruck nehme ich Mikades.
Statin am Abend? Wie viele Milligramen wissen Sie?
Das ist Artorastatin, das ist ein Zehner, den nehme ich abends.
Ok. Und Insulinpumpe, noch andere Medikamente?
Wie gesagt, Mikades und dann nehme ich noch Thebonin.
Und zwar habe ich seit, ja ich hatte vor anderthalb Jahren, ja anderthalb Jahren ist das her,
hatte ich einen Hörsturz und da ist mir ein Tinnitus geblieben.
Und deswegen nehme ich das Thebonin.
Thebonin. Nehmen Sie Thebonin. Wie viele Milligramen wissen Sie?
Das ist Thebonin 120.
120. Nehmen Sie dagegen oder welche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Blutdruck?
Mikades.
Mikades. Ok, ich habe das nicht verstanden. Wie viele Milligramen?
Ja das ist Mikades plus heißt das 40 zu 12,5. Dann nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
40, können Sie bitte die Dosierung wiederholen?
40 zu 12,5.
Ja, 12,5.
Eine morgens, eine abends.
Ok, ich verstehe. Gibt es noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen bei Blutdruck und Blutdruck und Tinnitus?
Wurde das schon mal operiert, Herr Haus?
Ne, tatsächlich noch nie.
Ok. Haben Sie noch eine bekannte Allergie?
Ja, ich bin allergisch auf Amoxicillin.
Amoxicillin.
Und dann bin ich auch allergisch, wenn im Frühling die Haselnüsse blühen, also dieser Pollenstaub.
Da kriege ich also so geschwollene Nase und so schnupfen und treiben die Augen.
Herr Haus, rauchen Sie?
Also man kann das eigentlich nicht Rauchen nennen. Ich rauche eigentlich immer nur aus Gesellschaften mit meinen Kollegen zusammen.
Wenn die zur Pause rausgehen, das sind so drei Zigaretten am Tag oder so. Aber ich bin eigentlich kein richtiger Raucher.
Ok. Seit wann haben Sie Zigaretten gehört?
Wann habe ich mit dieser Stelle angefangen? Damit ging das nämlich los. Ja, das ist 15 Jahre her.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Haus?
Ja, also ich trinke eigentlich gerne abends ein Glas Wein.
Jeder Abend?
Ja, so ziemlich. Und wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt, trinkt man auch mal ein Glas mehr oder ein Glas Sekt oder so.
Aber eben normalerweise eigentlich abends gerne ein Glas Wein.
Ja, aber es wäre besser, wenn Sie mit dem Rauchen und Alkoholkonsum reduzieren oder aufhören.
Das hilft mir aber jetzt auch nicht bei meinen Rückenschmerzen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, vielen Dank. Sie haben nicht nur eine Empfehlung. Oder nehmen Sie Drogen schon einmal?
Oh Gott, ja. In meinen wilden Zeiten in der Jugend habe ich mal Marihuana probiert und habe mal ein bisschen was geraucht.
Aber das ist schon lange her.
Herr Haus, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, so ziemlich. Mein Vater hat Hüftprobleme.
Er hat noch keine neue Hüfte, aber das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal fällig werden, wenn man das im Alter noch macht.
Meine Mutter hat ein bisschen Augenprobleme. Die Marihuana ist schlecht und muss regelmäßig zur augenerztlichen Behandlung.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind.
Okay. Herr Haus, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder. Die sind aber jetzt schon relativ groß.
Sehr sehr groß. Ist sie gesund?
Sind sie gesund? Ja, die sind schon gesund.
Ja, die sind schon gesund.
Und wollen Sie mit Ihrem Mann zusammen?
Mit meiner Frau. Ich bin ein Mann.
Die Kinder wohnen auch noch zu Hause, aber die sind schon relativ groß.
Was machen Sie bürgerlich?
Ich bin Ingenieur.
Ingenieur. In welche Branche arbeiten Sie?
In einer Firma. Ich bin in verschiedenen Fahrzeugen.
Bleiben Sie unter Stress beim Arbeiten?
Natürlich, bei der Arbeit hat man immer Stress.
Okay. Herr Haus, möchten Sie etwas hinzufrieden?
Nein, ich möchte jetzt natürlich nur wissen, was da los ist mit meinem Rücken.
Und auch natürlich, wann ich wieder vernünftig arbeiten kann.
Okay. Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich habe den Verdacht auf Bandscheibevorfall.
Oh, das wäre ja doof.
Aber es ist nicht so schlimm, dass ich nur eine Vermutung habe.
Um meine Diagnose zu bestätigen, brauchen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Erstens werde ich die körperlichen Untersuchungen dann etwas Probe abnehmen.
Dann werden wir eine Röntgen, eine Ländenröntgen, zwei Ebenen und einen MRT.
Okay, was kann man denn beim Röntgen überhaupt sehen?
Wir brauchen noch einen MRT.
Deswegen frage ich ja, muss man dann überhaupt noch Röntgen, wenn man sowieso einen MRT macht?
Ja, okay. Und anschließend werde ich einen orthopädischen Konsul anfordern für Sie.
Okay.
Ja, sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, ich bespreche mit meinem Obers und dann komme ich hin und erzähle Ihnen alles.
Wie es weitergeht. Ja, ich will natürlich auch wissen, was man dagegen tun kann. Ist ja klar.
Ja, okay.
Ich soll in ein paar Stunden hier bleiben. Ja, ich komme gleich.
Gut, ja. Möchte ich jemand von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch zusätzliche Fragen stellen?
Haben Sie früher Ähnlichkeit geschwärmt oder das ist das erste Mal?
Ja, also ich hatte, ich habe das eigentlich jetzt schon seit ein paar Monaten, dass immer dann, wenn ich viel im Garten gearbeitet habe,
dass ich dann ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen hatte, aber nicht so krass wie jetzt. Also das war längst nicht so schlimm.
Deswegen haben Sie Ihr Hausarzt früher besucht?
Nein, nein. Also das war nie so schlimm. Das ist immer wieder so von alleine weggegangen.
Dann habe ich mir so ein bisschen Wärme, also abends eine Wärmflasche im Bett oder so.
Dann ist es eigentlich nach ein paar Tagen wieder gut gewesen. Aber jetzt ist es halt wirklich viel heftiger.
Danke schön.
Gerne. Eine gute Zeit.
Gott sei Dank. Ich brauche ein paar Stunden.
Ja, klar. Alles gut. Vielleicht möchte ich doch jemand irgendwas fragen?
Guten Abend.
Hallo.
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und wenn Sie Zeit haben, ich möchte Ihnen ihn vorstellen.
Ja, gerne. Den haben Sie gesehen.
Es geht um Rainer Hass. 50 jährige Patienten, 19.05.1976 geboren und 1,80 Meter groß und
91 Kilo.
Schwer.
Ja, ein bisschen übergewichtig. Herr Hass stellte sich heute bei uns seit gestern plötzlich aufgetretene rechtseitige Beinschmerzen vor.
Laut Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen nach der eine schwere Hübel, nach der Hübel eines schweren Kübers plötzlich aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Beinen und in den Rücken.
Er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen sichern und stechen sind. Und seit gestern Abend der Patienten kann nicht bewegen.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 8 von 10.
Die Begleitung der Klangübe schmerzt bedingt die Düsseldienste seit gestern Abend.
Die Vekatativenamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Vekativenamnese ergab sich seit Kindheit mit Insulinpumpe behandelt.
Eine Arteriellhypatonie wurde mit Mikardis behandelt.
Die Hypocholestermin, dagegen nimmt er Statin und eine bekannte Tinnitus-Thionin 120 angenommen hatte.
Die Voroperation an Amnesis ist unauffällig.
Bei der Allergie an Amnesis hatte er eine bekannte Amoxylin- und Polenallergie.
Bei der Exposition reagierte er Geschwollen und Heusschnupfen.
Bei der Noxen-Anamnese erwähnte er seit 15 Jahren täglich 3 Zigaretten und einen Glaspain.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde als Jugendliche einmal bei Juana Beatt aktuell nicht.
Die Familien an Amnesis ergab eine Hüftprobleme beim Vater und Augenprobleme bei der Mutter.
Er ist verheiratet. Er hat zwei Kinder. Beide sind gesund.
Er wohnt mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Er ist Ingenieur und leidet unter Arbeitsbelastung.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf Diskus prolapsus.
In welcher Höhe?
In meiner Meinung nach 4 und 5.
Was könnte es Differentialdiagnostisch sein?
Differentialdiagnostisch kommen in eine Lumbargie und Spondyloarthros in Betracht.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ich werde ihn in der körperlichen Untersuchung...
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Neurologische Untersuchung ist sehr wichtig.
Was machen Sie da speziell?
Lossigtest, Babinski, Motornirrenuntersuchung, Motornerven, sensiblen Nerven.
Sie haben eine neurologische Untersuchung erwähnt.
Welche beiden Zeichen Sie checken?
Können Sie mir bitte helfen?
Ich sage aus. Reicht den Bein.
Ich glaube, Sie haben Lasek gesagt.
Lasek.
Und da gibt es noch einen?
Lasek und Babinski.
Und was noch? Kernisch gibt es noch.
Kernisch.
Das sind diese Nerven, Dehnungs, Schmerzen.
Worauf achten Sie noch?
Oft bei der Untersuchung.
Bei der Untersuchung?
Bei der Untersuchung.
Reflexuntersuchung ist sehr wichtig.
Bitte was?
Reflexuntersuchung.
Ja, klar. Aber außerhalb der neurologischen Untersuchung.
Worauf achten Sie, wenn Sie den Patienten körperlich untersuchen?
Ich habe mir nichts angefangen.
Sie haben den Patienten gefragt, ob die Haut anders aussieht, ob das Bein geschwollen ist, ob das Bein gerötet ist.
Das muss man natürlich noch mal verifizieren.
Aber trotzdem muss man das überprüfen, ob das richtig ist.
Aber natürlich.
Gut, was machen Sie noch mit Ihren Patienten?
Dann Blut abnehmen.
Irgendwelche Mobilkämpfe, Leber- und Nierenwerte und Ersündungswerte.
Sehr positiv Antikorps.
Etwas Rheumatest.
Das wäre auch noch interessant.
Und ich meine, da ist der Diabetiker. Vielleicht sollte man die Zuckerwerte auch noch mal so ein bisschen mitbestimmen.
Zuckerwerte Hemoglobin A1C.
HbA1C, genau.
Der Patient hat eine Hyperkolesternämie.
Könnte man noch die Blutwerte, ja. Wobei das wahrscheinlich mit der Diagnostik ja nicht so viel zu tun hat.
Gut.
Gut, was machen Sie weiter diagnostisch?
Ich möchte noch ein bildgebendes Verfahren.
Ja, ein bildgebendes Verfahren, ja.
Bei der Anamnese.
Mit einem Röntgen zwei Ebenen.
Mit welcher Fragestellung?
Mit welcher Fragestellung? Was schreiben Sie auf Ihren Röntgenschein drauf?
Ja, ich möchte einen Bein, zwei Ebenen und einen lehenden Röntgen.
Ja, was fragen Sie? Was sollen die checken? Was sollen die Prüfen, die Radiologen?
Radiologen, eh.
Was kann man im Röntgenbild sehen?
Ja, zum Beispiel Arthrose, Degenerations.
Also knöchernde Veränderungen könnte man sehen und natürlich eine Fraktur.
Ja, ja. Fraktur oder Degenerations.
Gut, aber für Ihre Hauptverdachtstiagnose brauchen Sie was für ein Verfahren?
Noch möchte ich einen MRT.
Genau, damit man sehen kann, ob da tatsächlich die Beinscheibe eingeklemmt ist.
Eine feste Diagnose zu stellen.
Ja, was wäre denn die Therapie, wenn Ihre Diagnose tatsächlich richtig ist?
Ja, ich fände auf, diese Patienten sollten ambulant behandelt.
Ich empfehle in Analgetika Muskelrelaxant und Physiotherapie.
Und Patientenschulung natürlich.
Und was?
Patientenschulung.
Patientenschulung in welcher Ansicht?
Lebensstilveränderung zum Beispiel, der Patient ein bisschen übergewichtig, 90 Kilo.
Zum Beispiel eine Diätestenz empfehlen könnte.
Und regelmäßig Sport treiben.
Na ja, okay.
Gesunde Ernährung und regelmäßig bewegen.
Ja, okay, gut. Ja, vielen Dank.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, was rauskommt, ob der Patient tatsächlich dann einen Prolaps hat.
Aber wenn der wirklich einen Prolaps hat und nicht nur, was weiß ich, eine kleine Irritation, geht der von alleine zurück?
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung kann ich eine Entscheidung treffen.
Okay, ja, gut. Aber ich denke mal, wenn tatsächlich ein Prolaps ist, der geht doch nicht von alleine zurück.
Ja, okay. Ich werde auf jeden Fall stationär aufnehmen.
Wenn sich das bestätigt.
Na gut, okay, gut.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir schon zur Manöverkritik.
Sie haben sehr schön systematisch gefragt und haben sehr nett den Patienten immer mit Namen angesprochen.
Das ist mir positiv aufgefallen.
Und ich musste nur ein bisschen grinsen.
Sie kennen den Fall, denn ich habe ja gar nicht gesagt, dass der schwer gehoben hat.
Sondern ich habe gesagt, der hat schwer gezogen.
Aber im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch haben Sie genau das wiedergegeben, was Sie von dem Fall wissen,
nämlich dass der schwer einen Blumenpot hochgehoben hat.
Hat der hier aber gar nicht gesagt.
Ich kann nur so viel sagen, ich war heute selber in meinem Garten und habe auch wieder so kleine Wurzeln rausgezogen.
Also so kleine Bäumchen, die so gerade fest wachsen.
Und es ist so mörderisch, wie man ziehen muss, damit der Kram rauskommt.
Man hat immer das Gefühl, einer kommt jetzt die Wurzel oder ich.
Der hat es nicht gesagt, aber Sie haben das wiedergegeben, weil Sie den Fall kennen.
Das ist natürlich gemein. Das ist auch ein klassischer Düsseldorfer Fall natürlich.
Am Anfang war ich ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, es war schwer zu ziehen.
Am Anfang kann ich nicht so gut verstanden.
Jedenfalls haben Sie den Blumenpot auch noch untergebracht.
In dem Augenblick, wo der Patient, haben Sie gemerkt, der wurde so ein bisschen unwillig.
Der wurde so ein bisschen unwillig, als Sie lauter Sachen gefragt haben, die eigentlich in die organische Krankheit reingehören.
Das hat ihm nicht so gepasst.
Der hat ja mehrfach gesagt, habe ich Ihnen auch schon gesagt, ich habe Rückenschmerz, nichts anderes.
Dann sollten Sie zumindest darauf eingehen und sagen, ich weiß, dass Ihnen das komisch vorkommt, aber wir müssen ausschließen.
Denn es gäbe ja auch noch eine relativ dramatische andere Differentialdiagnose.
Das wäre eine Metastasenbildung in der Wirbelsäule.
Dann eine spontane Verschlechterung durch diese Gartenarbeit, wenn der eine B-Symptomatik zeigen würde.
Hat er ja nicht, aber wenn er jetzt gesagt hätte, mir geht es schon seit einer Weile schlecht und ich habe immer so leichtes Fieber und abgenommen habe ich auch und nachts schwitze ich,
dann würde man natürlich sagen, was ist da mit der Wirbelsäule los, müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich weiß, dass Sie immer diese ganzen Fragenkatalog abfragen müssen, auch in dieser Prüfungssituation.
Aber wenn der Patient dann so unwillig reagiert, wie ich das gerade gemacht habe, sollten Sie das so ein bisschen glättchen und so das dann sagen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass Sie, die Fragen waren sehr systematisch, was mich ein bisschen genervt hat als Patient wiederum.
Die zwei, drei Zigaretten und das eine Glas Wein, das bringt den Mann wahrscheinlich nicht um.
Und das hat wahrscheinlich jetzt mit seiner akuten Erkrankung nicht viel zu tun.
Und da würde ich mir das auch verkneifen, den drauf anzusprechen, sie sollten aber keinen Alkohol trinken und sie sollten aber nicht rauchen.
Das will der in dem Augenblick echt nicht hören. Der hat Schmerzen bei acht von zehn.
Das ist schon ziemlich knackig. Da geht es dem wirklich nicht so gut.
Der kann sich kaum rühren und der hat wahrscheinlich gerade keine Lust, sich auch noch das Glas Wein am Abend verbieten zu lassen.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass man da sagen muss, selbst wenn der zehn Zigaretten geraucht hätte,
dann sollte man vielleicht sagen, ja, über das Rauchen sollten wir bei anderer Gelegenheit nochmal sprechen.
Jetzt kümmern wir uns mal um Ihre Schmerzen.
Ich habe das gesagt und dann dachte ich, das wäre nicht so gut.
Natürlich ist es nie gut, wenn man Alkohol trinkt und raucht.
Ein Glas Wein nicht so viel.
Inzwischen weiß man, dass jedes Glas Alkohol schlecht ist.
Das ist kein Geheimnis.
Aber es ist tatsächlich ja hier gerade in Deutschland eine absolut sozial anerkannte Droge.
Es wird massenhaft konsumiert.
Das ist einfach so.
Da waren Sie eigentlich durchgehend sprachlich relativ sicher.
Als der Patient ein bisschen nachgefragt hat, sind Sie da nicht drauf eingegangen.
Der hat ja gesagt, was kann man denn dagegen tun und so.
Da haben Sie aber eigentlich nicht viel gesagt.
Sie haben nur gesagt, ich vermute, dass Sie einen Mannscheibenvorfall haben.
Aber Näheres kann ich Ihnen erst sagen, wenn es so weit ist.
Gut.
Dann im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Das ist natürlich immer der kritischere Bereich, ist ganz klar.
Da ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie mit den Zahlen so ein bisschen Probleme hatten.
Das kam sehr langsam, sehr vorsichtig.
Der 50-jährige Patient, das lief noch.
Aber dann geboren am 19.5., haben Sie erst gesagt.
Und dann am 19.04.76. war dann richtig.
Aber das kam sehr, sehr langsam.
Und bei einer Größe von 1,80 m wiegt er 91 Kilo.
Oder das Gewicht gibt er mit 91 Kilo an bei einer Körpergröße von 1,80 m.
Gut.
Dann war das witzig, dass Sie gesagt haben, der Patient stellt sich.
Muss ich überlegen, ob ich das richtig hinkriege.
Stellt sich seit gestern Abend bestehende Schmerzen im LWS-Bereich, die ausstrahlen bei uns vor.
Das entscheidende Wegen.
Das haben Sie vor die Zerberung weggelassen.
Und das ist ja das, was immer grammatikalisch die Schwierigkeiten nach sich zieht.
Also er stellt sich wegen plötzlich aufgetretener, einschießender Lendenwirbelschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen strahlen ins rechte Bein aus.
Volle Beinlänge.
Und er ist eingeschränkt beweglich und er gibt Parastäsien an.
Gut.
Dann muss ich gucken, ob ich das richtig sage.
Ich habe mir das irgendwo aufgeschrieben.
Genau.
Die Vorerkrankungen haben Sie genannt und haben dann gesagt, der Diabetes Meditus wurde behandelt mit einer Insulinpumpe.
Nee, der wird immer noch behandelt.
Das muss man ins Präsens nehmen.
Das ist Gegenwart.
Er wird behandelt, nicht Vergangenheit.
Genauso wie das Statin, was er eben auch nimmt.
Das wurde nicht behandelt, sondern wird immer noch behandelt.
Oder Micades oder Artor Vastatin.
Bei einem haben Sie dann sehr elegant gesagt, wogegen er das und das einnimmt.
Das war dann richtig.
Aber es wird aktuell behandelt mit oder gegen den erhöhten Blutdruck nimmt er regelmäßig.
Das kann man auch sagen.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie schematisch sagen, die Noxenanamnese, die Familienanamnese, die Sozialanamnese haben Sie so ein bisschen abgehakt.
Das kann man auch ein bisschen eleganter formulieren.
Dass man eben sagt, auf die Frage nach Familienvorerkrankungen gab der Patient das und das an.
Die Augenprobleme hätte man, meine ich, ruhig ein bisschen exakter definieren können.
Die hat ja gesagt, die hat eine Makula Degeneration.
Gut, aber ja.
Und die Familienanamnese war dann auch klar, verheiratet zwei Kinder, beide gesund.
Jawoll.
Dann Verdachtdiagnose, klar, Diskuspola, das war schon klar.
Was nicht gekommen ist, Sie haben die Lasik- und Kernigzeichen und neurologische Tests und so was haben Sie erwähnt.
Was Sie nicht gesagt haben, Drogschmerz, Klopfschmerz über der Wirbelsäule.
Das müsste man tatsächlich checken.
Sie gucken ja praktisch am Ort des Geschehens, wo Sie was vermuten.
Und das Bein ist ja eigentlich nur Erfüllungsorgan.
Wo das hin ausstrahlt, weil da eben der entsprechende Nerv bedient wird.
Und das sollte man auf alle Fälle sagen, Klopfschmerz, Drogschmerz über der Wirbelsäule.
Und wichtig eben, wenn man röntgt, muss man dazu sagen, warum will man röntgen zum Frakturausschluss.
Das muss man hinschreiben.
Dann Therapie war genau, Schmerzmittel, Muskel-Relaxanz.
Und dann habe ich hier noch als Angabe, dass man unter CT-Kontrolle eine paravereitamorale Blockade machen könnte.
Aber Sie haben natürlich auch sehr elegant gesagt.
Dann werde ich ein orthopädisches Kunsthilfe anlassen.
Ja, klar, die Baustelle gibt man natürlich weiter.
Den Patienten behandeln Sie selber nicht weiter.
Gut, ja, dann.
Sprachlich machen Sie so ein paar Fehler noch.
Aber ich denke mal, das hält sich in Grenzen.
Wenn es ganz schlimm war, habe ich direkt korrigiert.
Das haben Sie vielleicht gemerkt.
Ich kann mir das immer gar nicht alles merken, was da so an sprachlichen Varianten ist.
Was mir eben aufgefallen ist, ist dieses falsche Teil, wurde behandelt, wird behandelt.
Und dann im entscheidenden ersten Satz das Wegen.
Das sollten Sie nicht vergessen.
Er stellte sich Wegen bei uns vor.
Oder man kann das auch, denke ich, ohne Not so machen.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor Wegen.
Aber der Genitiv, nach Wegen muss der Genitiv.
Das ist sonst unerträglich.
Ja, gut.
Ja, haben wir wieder viel gearbeitet heute Abend.
Sie waren sehr pünktlich fertig mit der Anamnese.
Beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch habe ich jetzt nicht so genau geguckt,
aber ich glaube, da waren Sie auch ziemlich gut in der Zeit.
Das war mit 20 Minuten so relativ exakt.
Also zeitlich sind Sie gut dabei.
Ja, dann ist jetzt schon wieder kurz vor dem Wochenende.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen einen netten Abend, ein gutes Wochenende.
Und ja, ich freue mich, wenn am Dienstag jemand Zeit und Lust hat, wieder mitzumachen.
Dann sehen wir uns gerne wieder am Dienstag und nächste Woche.
Dann bin ich dann also auch Dienstag und Donnerstag da.
Gut, für heute schönen Abend.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Mitarbeit und tschüss.
Danke für alles.
Ciao.